hey welcome to every damn day thank you
so much for watching this show this past
year we've had so much fun we've made
over 100 episodes thank you if you've
been with us from the beginning watching
and commenting we really appreciate it
we're about to take a little break don't
worry though we'll be back in 2019 with
some more exciting stuff keep coming
back to the comedy central YouTube page
for updates we're really excited for
what we've got in store for you guys for
next year however before we go we want
to leave you with what was my favorite
episode that we did all year it had our
full cast it involved a special guest
Tim Robinson he's one of my favorite
comedians promoting his show Detroiters
which is hilarious you should go check
it out and one of us got drunk in the
morning which was really fun and it's a
good bonding experience for us we hope
you liked it as much as I did check it
out right now take a little sip of the
stuff
okay that's a fork do anything myself
everybody we got special guest it's Tim
Robinson from Comedy Central's Detroiter
how this segment works we're gonna show
you some photos from these five people's
social media presents mm-hmm and all you
got to do is deduce if they are drunk in
the photo okay they're not gonna ask any
question I want about the photo how many
one three oh wait as many as you want
you can't just make up rules
anslee let's do the first photo find out
your face look at wrist this is a
wah-wah parking lot oh okay gas station
parking lot why did you take your shoes
off my feet were sweaty sweaty and you
took socks off too and you don't notice
whatever that green litter is next to
you yeah I want to say you're drunk
stone sober Oh long drive and then I got
a sandwich took your shoes off in a gas
station parking lot sober were you
crying you look like you've been crying
well I mean that we already answered the
drunk question let's go
oh that's
that's true well some questions I don't
know what beer that could be very first
beer and no sips what time is this 8
o'clock in night bar or like somebody's
basement it was a bar and we were about
to start a comedy show I'm gonna say
because of like that kind of like real
wet wall back there yeah it's soaking
wet which can't be good for the
mechanics of that moist moist bar I'm
gonna say you are for sure drunk in that
oh yeah I was drunk spectacular but I
was drunk okay oh I'm gonna say now drop
feels to like you you wouldn't do that
when you're drunk I think you wouldn't
dress like the mask if you were drunk
equipped to the Pichet chris is taking
it very literal yeah you got that big
bulge and he got a bold we can say this
but we can't do this oh yeah you're
right we can't say you're you don't
point at me while you're doing that was
our interpretation of the S&T road we
might not be quite right you were
pointing okay Wow kind of artsy I mean
is that Oh call yeah that's a beer and
there's two other beers going into the
beer this is like a magic guy
where are you Brooklyn Brewery you took
the phone you can see both of your hands
did no those are my friends that's the
trick there's three hands I'm holding
the beer two hands coming in didn't you
hold two beers and have your friend take
the photo that's that's that's like
normal as hell really bull what what
does that involve me this show has a
bully we should have warned you I'm
sorry dude that's pretty cool Jordan
drunk he's our bully drunk in this photo
ah no it's true
I just started drinking Wow like that
night my first drink was yeah that's my
first drink ever oh my god all right
Aynsley next murder in what time lunch
time 1:00 p.m.
lunch time and that's a corn dog with
ketchup dog seems like a drunk choice I
like that hat a lot real life I'm gonna
say you are drunk here
ending on a correct one but Tim guess
what that was just the pregame sir
the real game starts now one of you is
drunk right now
Tim secretly before we started taping
one of these people took three shots of
tequila based on the interactions you
just had and any further questions you
would like to ask who do you think is
drunk in the room somebody was a bully
could it be a mean drunk
it was tequila I think a nice brand of
tequila oh hey listen up er so I don't
think I didn't mean drunk at all you
gotta ask the audience or like call a
friend like if we got a man audience I'm
right here real dude support you cuz
like it's embarrassing if you're wrong